Brush like a Pro.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GENERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENT IS THE BASIC PREMISE
OF AMERICAN LIFE.
IN THIS COUNTRY, YOU CAN DO
BETTER THAN YOUR PARENTS.
THE MAIN DRIVER OF UPWARD
MOBILITY IN AMERICA IS HIGHER
EDUCATION.
GET AN EDUCATION WE TELL OUR
CHILDREN.
GO TO COLLEGE AND MAKES THEM
THING OF YOURSELF.
FOR MORE THAN 100 YEARS, THAT
HAS BEEN TRUE, BUT IS IT STILL
TRUE?
IS COLLEGE STILL WORTH IT?
FOR SOME, THE ANSWER IS
OBVIOUSLY US.
OUR PHYSICIANS, ENGINEERS, AND
RESEARCH SCIENTISTS ARE STILL
THE BEST AND APPROPRIATE FOR
THEM, COLLEGE IS ESSENTIAL AND
WELL WORTH IT.
WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF US?
HOW ABOUT YOUR AVERAGE SOCIOLOGY
MAJOR, POTABLE SCIENCE MAJOR AT
FILL-IN THE BLANK STATE YOU?
THAT REMAINS AN OPEN QUESTION.
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND THE NEXT
MONTH TRYING TO ANSWER IT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF WAYS TO
ASSESS THE COST AND BENEFITS OF
COLLEGE AND EFFECTS ON STUDENTS
AND THE MANY WAYS IT CHANGES IN
SOCIETY.
WE COULD TO ALL OF THOSE IN THIS
SERIES WHICH IS EVERY WEDNESDAY
NIGHT.
TONIGHT WE WANTED TO BEGIN WITH
THE ECONOMICS OF COLLEGE, THE
NUMBERS.
COLLEGE IS EXPENSIVE, THAT'S THE
FIRST THING TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
OVER THE PAST 30 YEARS, THE COST
OF A FOUR-YEAR EDUCATION AT A
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY HAS RISEN BY
213%, A RATE FAR FASTER THAN
INFLATION.
A LOT OF THAT COST IS FINANCED
FROM DEBT.
ABOUT 40 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE
STUDENT LOANS, OUTSTANDING
STUDENT LOAN DEBT IN THIS
COUNTRY AMOUNTS TO ABOUT